hello everyone good morning good morning
thank you it is so good to see everyone
here uh I'd like to get to know my
people before I start talking to you so
how many of you this is your first Tech
conference ever raise your hand
okay oh look at that lots of people with
their hands raised thank you
I have good news because this is an
amazing conference I have some bad news
going to an NDC event for your first
conference is like your first date being
with Beyonce like it's a really high bar
right but there's good news there are
NDC events all over the world so I would
say go to a few more before you try
going to other conferences all right
let's do another poll how many of you uh
this is your second NDC event hand up
okay hands up third
fourth
fifth
sixth
okay these are the folks who know where
the bathrooms are where the snacks are
so I hope you know that where their
hands are
so I have been in software development
for a very long time I started in 1997
so to age myself a long time ago I
worked for Accenture and for Deloitte I
was building Enterprise systems like
Oracle and sap and I still even all this
time later think that building software
is cool I think that is a that it is
amazing that we can take ones and zeros
and create value for our customers and
you know what this idea that software is
cool actually has has caught up with the
media right some of the biggest
companies in the world are tech
companies and so we always have like the
Mythology stories of a couple people in
a garage who are building what are now
multi-billion dollar companies
but there is a side of building software
that people don't really talk about
and that is building software can be
exhausting
and for a lot of people who don't build
software for a living this can be
surprising because when you think about
it our industry doesn't really require
physical labor right when you think
about this building and building this
this construct you see Brick and steel
and iron all these things so you can see
and imagine people sweating as they work
to build the building that we're
standing in right now
but the truth is that our industry does
exert a toll on the people who work in
it right that software developers that's
testers that's managers
we have so many constraints and burdens
that we have to bear right there's the
never-ending change in our industry
while that change can be exciting it can
be also exhausting when I started my
career there are technologies that I use
every day that don't even exist anymore
and there's so many new new cool Tunes
like you know Docker like back when I
was coming up uh I would walk downstairs
to the data center right I knew the
people who ran the data center by name
do you know the names of the people who
run your cloud service probably not
right so the industry has changed in so
many ways and it can be very difficult
to keep up with that rate of change
and then there is the burden of always
be shipping have you heard that term
before always be shipping now as an
engineering manager I've used that term
in my uh career to motivate Engineers to
keep shipping software right because the
idea is that if we are able as a team to
continuously deliver value to our
customers then we're able to show the
value that we bring to the company
but the fact is that any system that is
always on will fail
and and I've seen that in my career I am
before you as someone talking about
burnout because I've experienced burnout
I've been there I know how it feels and
the fact is that in our industry when
people burn out they often burn down
things with them
right you see people burning out of the
architectures that we're using and I've
had Engineers you know we're using
reacts and then suddenly they're
installing angular and like we're not
using this framework right but they're
trying to cope with burnout
and also people begin to burn down the
the methods and and the practices that
we're using
um and so they begin to do other things
than the processes that we're trying to
use for building our software
and I'm here today to say that it
doesn't have to be this way it there are
better ways to manage teams there are
better ways to work in our industry to
build up what I call burnout resistance
uh and that is the ability to withstand
the stress in our industry uh and to be
able to not fall into birdout
now just to give a bit of an overview
over what we're going to talk about I'm
going to start with what is the problem
right let's define the problem I've
worked with a lot of product managers
and one of the things that they always
say is what is the problem that we're
trying to solve right so we're going to
define the problem then we're going to
talk about common solutions to that
problem right burnout is as you'll see
very widespread uh and we're going to
talk about ways that people try to treat
and to mitigate their burnout and then
we're going to talk about what I call
the burnout resistance framework and
it's a very common sense lightweight way
to go about your day and I hope to share
things that you can that you can begin
to implement like right now like today
uh what can you do to help build up your
burnout resistance and then just
kind of put a bow on it and this is the
keynote version so this is one that I
don't usually get to share I'm going to
talk about what do you do when your
resources are scarce well you don't have
a lot to pull on and you're battling
burnout
so I also want to say that I usually
give this talk with my wife and uh she
could not make the trip uh this this go
around uh so I'm flying solo now she has
the PHD and I'm just an engineer who
uses like Wikipedia so
um I often rely on her to kind of go
into some of the research behind burnout
and so I'm going to give both my part
and her part but you know if my wife
sees this I wish you were here I love
you I will do it next time together all
right so let's go into uh what is
burnout well if you look at the
definition of burnout you'll find this
so uh World Psychiatry uh defined
burnout and I'm going to put a little
bit of text on screen but it's a
syndrome that has three key Dimensions
right and that's overwhelming exhaustion
that cynicism and Detachment and a sense
of of ineffectiveness and a lack of
accomplishment now I'm sure that a lot
of you have probably felt all three of
these things so this is the definition
of burnout but my wife and I like to
boil it down to this working definition
of burnout uh and that's the ongoing
feeling that today's resources are not
enough to meet tomorrow's the mass has
anyone ever felt that way
they're like the way that you feel right
now it's like you know you can't even
see having time to do what you what you
need to do today
let alone tomorrow and so that ongoing
feeling is what I like to describe as
burnout now there are three dimensions
of burnout
so there's the exhaustion right and so
this can be physical but often it's
emotional you feel that there's like
nothing left to give maybe you've after
a long day at work whether you're
working in an office or working at home
you just feel like oh there's nothing
left to give you can't even like stream
Netflix because there's so many things
that you've been tasked to do uh that
you don't even have any energy for
anything or anyone else so maybe your
partner needs time from you or your
children need time for you but you just
don't have anything left to give all
right the second dimension is
depersonalization uh and that is when
humans stop being people and become
objects and the way that I like to
describe this is you know you ever go to
let's say a a hospital because a friend
maybe was in an accident and then you
ask where your friend is when you get
there and then the person says oh
they're broken or term they're in room
three right your friend has ceased to
become a person to that worker that's
when you de-personalize someone and we
all work with people it is easy to
forget that they're humans uh that
they're people that engage in the work
that you're doing and we can forget that
these are people that we're working with
and it's easy between engineering and
product or design our managers and ICS
to feel that people are on the other
side but when you're burned out it gets
even worse right you begin to forget
that we're just all people doing our
best trying to make our jobs work and
then the third element
is you don't feel accomplishment right
the things that used to satisfy you
early in your career uh maybe even last
week you don't feel any satisfaction in
that anymore right so these are the
three dimensions of burnout so
when we think about
uh burnout and you may think about well
how widespread is bird out well it's
pretty widespread right Gallup did a
survey and this was pre-pandemic by the
way and they said that uh of a survey of
70 of 7 500 employees that 23 percent
reported feeling burned out at work
right almost a quarter
um and then 44 said that they felt
burned out sometimes so we see that
burnout is very very widespread
now
you may have also um work be saying okay
but these two-thirds of full-time
workers experience the burnout
um what do we understand about
engagement now A A lot of people think
that the opposite of burnout is
engagement so so what's engagement right
engagement is when you have the people
in your team who are always in slack and
they're always on Zoom calls and they're
smiling and whenever there's an office
activity to the first people to arrive
the last people to live are to leave and
like you're like these are the people
who are like they're they're all the way
in they're dialed in and you believe
that like these people like when aren't
thinking about quitting right because
they're always down into what's
happening
and you may also say that our office is
amazing right we have pool tables we
have a beer keg in the break room we
have snacks we bring in meals for
everybody and you may think that
everyone is really dialed into what
we're doing but
uh Cambridge uh did a survey and they
found that for the engaged people the
people who were the most engaged were
the ones who were thinking about leaving
their jobs
right so the people who are the most
active the people who are the most
visible the people who you think will be
the last people to leave are often
updating their resumes and looking for
work
and the highly exhausted uh engaged
group are the people who again are the
most prone to burning out and I know in
my career whenever I've been at the end
of my rope I've been to think okay well
let me just do like one last push to try
to make this work and I know that I've
probably know that I'm engaged when I'm
actually burned out right and so it's
important to not confuse that that
they're not confuse engagement with
burnout
all right now there are several calls to
burn out and there are individual costs
that we all have to pay
um and so Mayo Clinic classified a few
of the symptoms of burnout so you may be
wondering okay am I burned out well
maybe you have these symptoms uh there's
physical illness right like fatigue and
high blood pressure uh there are uh
distress right we emotions ranging from
sadness to being irritated to even
feeling rain rage uh and there's like
also maybe increased sick days right so
you may have seen people at your company
begin to take more time off saying that
they're not feeling well and then maybe
it's like one sick day a quarter then
it's one sick day a month then one sick
day a week right those are signs that
that person may actually be burned out
so those are the individual costs of
burned out but there are also Corporate
calls as well uh Harvard Business School
uh did a survey and they found that if
you added up the cost of burnout it
ranges from 125 to 190 billion dollars
can you imagine right how much lost
productivity that is and not only that
but the highest factor in these costs
were demanded work and that resulted in
48 billion dollars in spending so when
we look at burnout we see that there's
enormous individual costs but there's
also enormous corporate costs as well
now
given that burnout is so widespread it's
not surprising that people often try to
find ways to combat burnout and there
are two major categories that people try
to try to cope with burnout there are
corporate methods and in the visual
methods and I'm going to go through a
few of those methods and really explain
why they may not be very effective all
right so first
a lot of Corporations try to create
these Swanky office spaces right so I
work at GitHub I've been to a few of the
offices uh and they are nice right
they're really well laid out uh some
some companies even bring in uh people
to do yoga in the yard uh and they'll
have all these benefits that are meant
to help people feel better about coming
to work and often these companies they
spend a ton of money to make developers
feel like royalty
but sometimes royalty winds up at the
Red Wedding and then no matter what you
do uh no matter how nice the coffee
machine or the espresso machine is in in
the office uh people who get to that
state like none of that matters and so
the reason that corporations even though
they are well-meaning aren't really
great at finding burnout it's because
when times get hard uh when a recession
hits those are often the first things
that get cut from the budget right uh
that's sabbatical that you've been
banking on for several years may go away
uh and so often corporations are not
effective at helping the people who work
there uh combat burnout so I don't
really think that corporations are the
place to go for it for an answer but
then there are individual ways to try to
combat burnout
uh there's escapism right so this
picture is someone who's running along
the beach uh trying to get away from it
all uh I don't know about you but one of
my favorite ways to exercise self-care
is going on a vacation going on a trip
especially with the world being opened
up again
and I think that the problem with that
is that it becomes almost a performance
right how many of you have gone on a
trip and you're always taking pictures
right doing it for the gram or doing it
for the tick tock and trying to document
uh what you're doing like we're working
hard to show how much we're not working
uh and that can also exert a toll on on
people who are dealing with burnout we
haven't had people falling off the Grand
Canyon and falling off uh High Cliffs
right trying to get that that perfect
picture
and we also often go to excess we begin
to abuse food and alcohol maybe even
drugs how to try to deal with with our
burnout and so we find that corporate
efforts often fall short and even our
own individual efforts uh don't solve
the problem
and so my wife and I looked at a ton of
research and we try to come up with the
framework for building burnout
resistance
and we wanted something that was really
Common Sense we wanted something that
people could get we didn't want it to be
something that you needed to have a PhD
to figure out because my wife has one of
those but we wanted to be something that
people could understand and we wanted it
to be something that we did not need a
lot of privilege to bring into bear and
so this framework has three parts and
I'm going to go through each part of the
framework in this talk and I'm going to
give you an example of how it works and
then I'm going to also for each part do
what I call the one thing you simply
must do to hopefully drive home each
part all right so let's Dive In
um now this is called managing the
burnout burn down because I am an
engineering manager and I've been a
scrum master
um and so a lot of you have heard of a
burn down track have you ever heard
about that a burn down chart yeah yeah I
know some of you probably sick of them
I've gotten sick of them uh over the
years but I've always come back to them
as a very useful way to understand
um uh work right where the team is so
for those of you who don't know uh those
of you who may be early in your careers
um a burden that chart is really very
simple uh you have an x-axis which is
time right this is usually measured in
days then you have a y-axis uh which
represents work uh and that work can be
several forms a lot of you are familiar
with story points uh and measuring work
with that but it could be there are a
couple ways that you can measure work
and the idea is that you have this ideal
line right this ideal line is simply if
the work burned down a certain amount
every day then it will get down to zero
right so that's the ideal line and then
you have as you go throughout uh the
period and we usually use Sprints uh you
track how is the work burning down how
much work is being done and so this
becomes the amount of work that is
becoming less uh and so the idea behind
a burn down chart uh is that you want
the work to go down to zero and the real
utility of a burn down chart is that you
have a graphical representation of where
the work is Right are we on schedule are
we behind schedule so it's a very easy
way to help track the work and so as the
scrum master and as an inch manager I've
often spent many late nights looking at
burn down charts and trying to see okay
where is the work and how is my team in
relation to the work
but but over time as I began to work
with burnout teams I realized that I
needed to do more than just burn down
work uh there were certain things going
on in the lives of the people that I was
working with that I also needed to help
them burn down uh and so this talk talks
about the ways that you can burn down
the things that often lead to stress
all right
the first part of the framework is
burning down barriers
burning down barriers now we work in
teams because teams can accomplish more
than we can as in the visuals and it's
really important that as we work
together and you know during the
pandemic uh it was really hard because
most of us often were confined to home
or we weren't able to move around but I
think that as that pandemic has ease
we've all gotten back to working
together
and whether you work in an office or you
work fully remote or some hybrid
situation uh the people that you work
with it's really easy to build up
barriers right because we all have
deadlines we all have pressure and
there's an old saying that says that if
you want to go fast go alone but if you
want to go far go together and I love
that saying because it means that if we
take the time to connect with each other
then we'll get so much more done
and then I really encourage you to as
you think about the people that that
you're working with uh there may be some
some stresses right I've worked with a
lot of people in my career and I'm going
to tell you I have not always gone along
with everyone that I've worked with
um but I've had to figure out how to
make it work because the task at hand
the match that we work together
and so it's really important that we
find ways to optimize the relationships
between us and the people that we work
with and I think that there are lots of
ways that companies can help people do
this uh the way that you arrange working
places and how you structure teams uh is
one way uh having effective culture is
also a great way to to do that making
sure that you have uh cultural
constructs that support people working
together
um I I GitHub one of the things that we
do is we have in-person mini Summits and
so we fly people in different teams to
the same location uh to just spend time
together because even though we have all
these Cool Tools like you know we have
zoom we have slack and all these and all
these tools there's really nothing like
getting together in person and what we
find is that as we make the
relationships of the people that we work
with richer as we take time to
acknowledge their Humanity as we make
space for beautiful respect we get
better outcomes we get better working
relationships as we get to know each
other better and so I really encourage
you to think about right now some of the
people that at work that you're not
getting along with right maybe there's
uh disagreements about uh technology uh
choice or maybe people feel that the
engineering team is getting ahead of
product and design right I've I've been
there and what I encourage you to do is
try to reach out to that person whoever
that person may be and try to find
common ground
trying to find something that you agree
on and then from there try to figure out
well what needs to be true for you to
move forward and one of the things that
I help my Engineers do when they come to
me with this challenge is try to figure
out okay what would need to be true for
that person again for them to come
around to your perspective but before
you do that just just listen right don't
listen to when the argument don't listen
to try to you know wait for that person
to stop talking so that you can make
your points but seek to understand seek
to understand I think that often we
forget that that conversations are meant
for people to understand each other and
I think that often it's important to
kind of make that first step and so for
this part of the framework the one thing
that you simply must do uh is just meet
in person on a regular basis I know it
sounds simple but it's really effective
it's really easy for us to work in silos
uh to especially if you're working from
home to just not even talk to people for
several days at a time but I encourage
you to just meet with people uh who who
you work with
um at my previous company and even at
GitHub we have a slack robot called
um I think it's called donuts and my
previous company is called donut I think
it's called something else I get help
but the idea is that it's just a little
application uh I think it's called Bagel
uh that will just pair you up right and
it'll just randomly pair you up with
someone and then you can hop on a zoom
and just talk uh and so
I've met so many people who um who
aren't even Engineers uh by this big old
bot that just pairs me up and and it's
just very simple we get together we get
to know each other
um and I have already found it super
useful because that person that I had a
chat with like a month ago I now need
something from that person right and so
like these little uh slack Bots whatever
tool that you use or you can replicate
it in various ways is super important
and as an inch manager I really never
liked that the first time I asked
someone for something uh the first time
that I talked to someone it's like I
need something from that person right
and so by having those conversations by
making time to get to know people as
people then when you really need
something you've already laid the
groundwork there's an old proverb uh I
like the quote that says dig your well
before you're thirsty right Bill though
dig that emotional well build uh build
that respect well before you need it and
that makes it so much easier to work
with people afterwards all right so the
first part is burning down barriers the
things that separate us
the second part is burning down
distractions
now we live in a culture where there's
always something to take our attention
away from the task at hand
and like this is really different from
the past right when people worked in
factories right you really couldn't
bring a Model T home to work on uh but
now we can work anywhere so I mean many
of you could pull out your phones right
now and log into GitHub or whatever you
use for Source control and actually
start doing work you can review PR's
standing right here right now you can do
that at home you can do that when you're
in the shower right you can do that
almost anywhere and so the almost ever
present nature of work uh means that we
can also be overpowered by that work but
does not just work right or our phones
have many distractions uh their social
media sites their streaming services
there are all these things that are
combating for your attention
but the fact is that your attention is
very limited and most of us don't think
about this but our brains are wired to
only be able to focus on a few things
for a certain period of time and when
you exhaust the attention of your brain
then you lose the ability to process new
information and so the takeaway from
this and and the reason that this helps
with burn out uh is that if you use the
power of no you'll find that you'll get
more things done but you also open the
doors to saying yes to something else
later and and I know that often it's
really hard to say no uh if you're here
at NDC right you're working in
development and people who build code
are often hyper motivated people uh and
Hyper motivated people like to say yes
to a lot of things uh you know I mean
coding requires a lot of Hope right
because we're writing code that is
interpreted by a compiler or at runtime
uh that you hope works right and so we
lean into hard things but I encourage
you to understand that that no is also
very very powerful and what I would hope
that everyone can do
either now or later tonight is think
about what are your values
right what are the things that you're
placed on the planet to do everyone here
has a set of things that you're built
for
and what you can do is when you think
about okay what are my values what are
the things that really light the fire of
my heart that give me passion and energy
and then just align your work with those
values and you have to be able to say
that even though this thing that I'm
being asked to do is cool or interesting
or I want to do it to make somebody
happy you have to learn to say no
you have to learn to say I'm going to
pass on this uh because there's other
things that I need to spend my limited
attention on
and I know it's hard and I've had to
develop my my no muscles uh in time and
there are really easy ways to do that
you can say hey I would love to help out
with that uh but here's what I'm working
on now can you help me understand why
the thing that you're asking me to do is
more valuable to than than that plate of
work right now that requires that you
always know what you're working on that
you're tracking your work uh and so it's
really important that you do that but by
doing that then you give that person a
view like what your values are and then
when you're saying no then they know
that you're not saying no to them as a
person you're saying no to the
distraction of what really is valuable
to you there's other techniques of
saying no that I can talk about after
but no is so powerful and I think that's
a it's something that we don't utilize
very often uh because we often want
people to like us and we think that's
saying yes means people will like us uh
but if you get burned out then you won't
be able to deliver on that thing that
you said yes to but it really it
requires going through your values and
aligning your work with the values
so
what is the one thing that you simply
must do to burn down distractions well
one of the things that I like to do is
is a social media fast and I know that
some of you grew up on you know Twitter
and now there's all these other things
that my children use that I don't even
know about like Snapchat or or other
tools
but I find that whenever I just
uninstall those apps from my phone for a
period of time and you can do this I can
tell you you can do this
um but that frees up so much of my
mental weight right so that frees up so
much mental space for me to not to
resist the urge to like and scroll
through Tick Tock scroll through
Instagram
um and so I'm able to free up that time
for again the things that align with my
values now I'm not saying to do it
forever I will say try it for a week uh
see how you feel if you like it keep
going right then again these tools do
have value but I think that they exert
and an outsized drain on our attention
and by doing that then they they lower
our ability to resist burnout because
we're stressed out by all the things
that we're being distracted by
all right so the last part of this
framework
um oh actually I I have bonus content
because I'm doing the keynote I'm I'm at
in at NDC so when we talk about Focus
yes it's really important that you very
much constrain your focus to the things
that really align with your values uh
but I'd like to practice uh mindfulness
and so one of the ways that I like to do
that is in something that we all do
every day and that's eating
and I'm just going to ask people to do
something the next time you eat and the
good news is that this great food at
this conference and NDC always rocks the
food
but so many of us and I know I've been
there because we're often rushing to do
things or we're trying to maybe like
watch a video while we eat
I've eaten food that food that I like
don't even remember what I ate I don't
remember what it tasted like
um and I I just eat and then rush
through and then move on and so I
totally miss out on the joys of eating
and Studies have shown that we have to
chew our food more often now they say
that you should chew your food 32 times
right that's a lot of of chewing and I
saw I totally get that but the idea is
that you chew your food that's every
mouthful of food uh 32 touch I know this
seems kind of silly then you actually
break it down more you extract more
nutrients from the food you make it
easier to digest and so that process of
just chewing the food actually is
powerful so maybe not 32 I would say 10
times so when you eat lunch try true
your food 10 times before you swallow it
and what you'll find is that one you're
actually tasting the food that has been
beautifully prepared by the vendors here
for the people who are catering and
you'll feel better and then you'll
actually be able to think about the food
that you're eating and that's just one
way to focus on the task at hand right
so many things in this world we do and
our minds are elsewhere we're totally
not even connected to what's going on
right right now and the simple practice
as a way for you to just connect with
the thing that you have to do to avoid
dying and that's eating so like that's
my you can do that today you can do that
in like three hours just chew everything
10 times
you can add me on Twitter if you think
that this kind of poppycock but I'm
telling you it makes a difference all
right
all right
so the last part of this framework uh is
burning down illness now we all walk
around in these meat sacks right that
we're constrained to and so uh we have
to travel around in in in bodies uh and
the challenge is that often we don't
treat our bodies very well uh we may not
get enough water we may not get enough
sleep and when you when you do that to
yourself then you limit your ability to
to resist stress right because when
you're well rested when you're properly
hydrated uh when you do things to
exercise your your body then you
actually become more resistant to stress
because your body has the reserves that
it needs to deal with stress and so the
the key to this is to
find time to take care of your body
and I know it's difficult uh I flew from
Texas on Sunday night and I landed on
Monday and I've probably gotten maybe an
average of like three hours of sleep at
night since I've been here right so I'm
like I'm working through my failure to
not really do a good kind of body work
but it's critically important that we
take care of ourselves that we take the
time to mine our bodies so we take the
time to think about you know what are we
doing to enhance our health I know that
with my teams I obviously can't force
them to do anything but I always try to
make sure that if I sit in working late
like they answered that late night slack
or they send that late night email let
us know hey it can wait until tomorrow
right as your manager I'm saying that
you don't need to to uh to spend late
nights doing that that's something that
you should better spend with your with
your loved ones uh and and getting a
better night's sleep right
um and so like what's the one thing that
you simply must do well that is and I
think that the area that there's the the
the best control over that you can get
the most value of is is sleeping uh and
my wife and I have done a lot of things
to upgrade our our sleep our Sleep
Quality uh We've invested in uh a
weighted blanket uh which has worked
wonders uh We've lowered the temperature
in our bedroom uh by several degrees and
we sleep better we use a white noise uh
audio file in Google music while we
sleep and so all those things have
resulted in better sleep and I and I
find that whenever I do those things
whenever I get a good night's sleep like
I'm a better engineer uh when I'm better
arrested I'm a better manager when I'm
well rested uh and I'm less irritable
and I can focus more and things are more
clear and so the simplest thing of just
working on your sleep can do wonders
so those are the three parts of the
framework and so I want to go back to
the burn down chart uh because you have
the idea of the ideal line
and I really like the ideal line so for
those of you who aren't familiar the
ideal line is just that that line that
like I said before that if you perfectly
burn down the work then it'll burn down
evenly every day and so the team will
get down to zero
and the way that the ideal line Works uh
is that you know if you're above the
line then you are running behind
schedule but if you're below the line
then you're in front of the schedule
and
I used to again obsessed about the ideal
line because I would look and see
where's the team every day uh based on
are they above or under the the line
but in time as I work with my teams I
began to not stress out so much about
this ideal line
and it's really about tolerance it's
really about the practices that my teams
are going through the burn down chart is
a useful metaphor right but it is simply
the beginning of the story it's not the
end of the story it's simply a snapshot
in time of where the team is and it's so
much better that we use that tool for
what it's good for which is that
snapshot but it's really meant to ask
conversations and that those
conversations should be around how we're
doing with our practices how are we
doing with uh with our daily stand-up
how are we doing with our engineering
practices how are we doing with the way
that we do PRS our code reviews how are
we doing with the ways that we
communicate right those practices are so
much more important than the burn down
chart
and I say that because you can get
burned out trying to avoid burnout and I
don't want people to obsess over the
things that I shared with you and so
you're you're going to never perfectly
manage your life as an engineer right
every day is going to have error it may
be error in the code that you're writing
it may be error in the communications
between the engineering team and the
product team and design and it may be
errors in how the leadership of the
company uh is dictating how things go
and so that's just going to happen
and the same thing happens with how we
manage our stress how we deal with the
things that happen to us and so it's
less important to do all the things all
of these things perfectly but it's
really important that we understand what
is our tolerance
right if like right now if I'm not
getting the proper sleep I know that I
can go for a couple days but I know that
when I get home I'm going to sleep like
a solid you know eight hours a night
there may be times in your life where
your relationships aren't where they are
maybe those are your relationships at
work when you're maybe not getting along
with a lot of people are in your
personal life like that's okay if that
happens for a certain amount of time but
it's really important that you take the
time to tend to those relationships
and there may be times where you are
distracted right you're a manager or
someone else may put a lot of things on
your plate right you might have some
kind of deadline uh GitHub has Universe
coming up which is our big annual
conference uh coming up in November uh
it's the first time coming back to being
in person I'm super excited about that
uh and so my team has deadlines that are
tied to GitHub universe that we're
working toward and so that is adding a
lot of pressure and I feel that I need
to do a lot of work with my team to make
sure that they're not feeling
overwhelmed by this deadline and so this
framework is meant to be a guideline but
it's also meant to show that it is a way
for us to interrogate the reality of our
lives and see where we are and the best
way to do that is to just have a check
in with yourself right I do a personal
retrospective every week at the end of
the week I look over what happened to me
during that week and I try to figure out
how did I do with my health
how did I do with my relationships how
did I do with my ability to focus
was my calendar managed or was it
overwhelmed with meetings and work uh do
I is my test is my test is getting
shorter or is it just getting longer and
longer every day and so that Weekly
check-in is my way of using this
framework to make Corrections because I
can make Corrections in my relationships
I can go to that person that I'm having
maybe a disagreement with and say you
know what let's just kind of go for a
walk if we're in the same place or let's
hop on a zoom chat and just chat about
what's going on
um I can fix things that are going on
with with my health right I can double
down on eating better I can double that
on chewing my food before I swallow it I
can double down on getting better sleep
right so these things can be corrected
and I don't want people to get stressed
out because you may be thinking you know
what my relationships are kind of trash
right now uh I've pissed off a lot of
people or I haven't stopped much in the
past three days uh and all I eat is junk
food or you know I every day there's
more to do than the day before
there are ways for you to work on that
but it starts like right now right it
starts with taking time to get better
practices so don't worry about
perfection work on your practices
all right so but what about scarce
resources so I shared a lot with you I
hope that everyone got something that
you can say okay I can do that I can
work on getting better sleep I can work
on working out maybe more consistently
or I can work on saying no right those
are all simple things that everyone in
here can do
but
hey we all have scarce resources like we
work in technology which is a industry
that typically pays very well so you may
feel like well my resources aren't
aren't scarce but you know money is not
the only resource right time is a
resource energy is a resource and so
what I want to do is share a couple of
things that you can do when you're short
on time short on energy short on other
resources to make this framework work
all right so the first one is about
volunteering right so I'm an introvert
people are surprised by that because I
get on stage and talk in front of large
audiences on a regular basis but no I am
a classic introvert and so that means
that I get drained by being around a lot
of people and I love people I mean come
up and talk to me afterwards come up and
you know if you want to if you add me on
Twitter I will more than likely respond
uh at least eventually uh but I get
drained by human interaction so this
relationship part of the framework I
have to admit I struggle with uh because
I'm drained by being around lots of
people I'm drained by by noise and what
I found is that like the cheat code for
this is volunteering uh and Microsoft
and GitHub have we have a great benefit
where uh the hours that we spend on
volunteering uh can result in matching
from the company and your companies may
have things like that uh and I really
think that some of you may have
volunteered before the pandemic but
since you were maybe forced to
quarantine you fell out of doing that I
highly recommend that you pick that back
up because like it is a built-in way to
build relationships because you're
around people who are passionate about
something that you're passionate about
too right because that's why you're
volunteering and I think that that can
be a powerful way to just get out of
being introverted get out being away
from people and to meet other people and
and contribute to a worthy cause
um the way that I do this is is by
mentoring right I'm part of a group that
mentors people who are new to technology
who are entering the field uh and so
that gives me the opportunity to every
day talk to people who are passionate
about that too and so I know a lot of
you have have you know volunteered and
again you may be in a situation where I
used to volunteer but
um the pandemic kind of shut that down
might not re-engage right why not show
up at the next meeting why not uh email
the organizer and say hey I know I've
been there in a while let me get back
into that and by doing that by being
around around other people you'll find
that you have people who you can talk to
right so many Studies have shown that
simply the process of talking about your
problems make those problems easier and
what my friends and I do what we try to
do on a regular basis is get together
and say like what is the one thing that
is pissing you off right now right and
we have honest conversations about that
and often the benefit of that exercise
isn't that they solve my problems it's
not that that pissed off thing that is
bothering me goes away
but is talking with people who
understand like what I do they
understand me and simply by doing that
that thing that is pissing me off
becomes less stressful because I've
shared it with other people I've said
the thing out loud that I've been
carrying inside myself often for weeks
and so that that's powerful so
volunteering is a way for you to find
those people that you can talk to and
that you can do something that you're
passionate about but get that kind of
trusted Circle to have honest
conversations
all right and so uh what about Focus
right so I talked about the power of
focus and and the power of of saying no
you might be like I'm really
overburdened and my job requires me to
be always doing 200 things all at once
and I understand that
but if you're have scarce scarcity in
terms of time to say no I do recommend
journaling as a practice and you know I
have journals that I've kept
electronically over the years if you
name a journaling tool I've used it I've
used Evernote I've used OneNote I've
used whatever note is out there uh to a
journal but I've actually found that
like physically writing down my journal
is super powerful and so for a while I
went back to paper journals so I would
have just a journal that I would just
get a pin and just write in and just
write what I'm thinking about I would
just write out my thoughts and I even
have Journal prompts that I would
respond to uh tell me kind of make that
a more faithful practice
and right now I've I've converted to
using uh an app called notability on the
iPad and an apple pencil so that I have
the ability to have that kind of writing
exercise but it's it's all you know
electronic right it's saved on my iPad
and so the reason that I do that is that
I find that the act of like writing out
my thoughts makes me feel that I'm
getting them out of my head and I find
that the ability to get those thoughts
out of my head gives me space to not
worry about that
and it also gives me space to kind of
put in new things into my mind right and
one of the best aspects of journaling is
that when you look back a week a month a
quarter or a few years
you'll find that wow those things that
were really bothering me when I wrote
that like that became nothing right
there was like that was such a non-issue
and as you do that as you journal and
you have time to reflect then you'll be
able to see that over time most of the
things that we're worried about
happening actually never happen
and then what you'll be able to do is
that you realize that I should probably
stop worrying about things so much and
so again it's a very simple thing
hopefully everyone has access to paper
and Pen uh but that's something that you
can start tonight right you can begin to
journal uh get those thoughts out of
your head on to a more permanent form uh
and I think that you'll find that that
lets you focus on what's really
important
but you may feel that hey this exercise
thing sounds great but I don't have time
to go to the gym
um you know going to the gym is really
expensive I know that every time I start
working out so like I've worked out on
and off over my you know almost 50 years
on the planet and like what's the first
thing that I do when I start working out
right I buy workout clothes right you
know I'm not sure if you're you but I
get like the leggings and I get the
shirt and I get you know I hit up like
you know Lululemon and I you know dig
myself out and then those clothes are
used for me those clothes are used for
maybe like six months and then I I stop
and then I redo it right so I always get
caught in this trap of like buying
workout gear so I understand working out
can be um limiting can be hard to find
time it can be hard to go you know find
a gym that that works for you a gym
that's close enough buy to you and so I
understand that finding time to work out
can be challenging but I think that
taking a walk is is a really easy
low-cost way to exercise
if you live in a place that I assume is
safe to walk around outside of that some
people don't but my wife and I actually
started to practice uh every day after
dinner we just go for a walk we'll just
walk a few blocks that gives us time to
catch up with what happened during
during the day uh we break it like a
light Sweat by doing that because we
walk at a pretty good pace and the
simple practice of walking
has been enormously successful in
building up my burnout resistance right
because I get a chance to work on my
body it's something that I can do on a
regular basis I could connect with my
partner in life and so I just I just
really encourage everyone to just take
just take a walk take a walk maybe not
every day but on a regular basis maybe
three times a week make time to take a
walk
so those are ways that you can hopefully
uh with very limited Investments of time
and resources uh managed burnout
I think that is critically important
that we do this you know I think that a
lot of us are going to be defined by
what happened in 2020 Right This Global
pandemic that hit the world and I know
that a lot of you are stressed out about
it right you're stressed out about
having to live through that time uh in
life but I really think that we can take
this thing that happened to everyone
here and use it as a springboard to
doing something better
that we can be the generation that yes
we were locked down for for two years uh
but we came out better for it we came
out more resilient we came out with a
better understanding of what's important
in life and I really hope that you all
can see that as an opportunity to become
the better version of yourself
right I know that the pandemic hit my
family hard my kids uh had to like learn
from home uh and my oldest son is
applying for colleges and he wrote an
essay about what happened during the
pandemic and he admitted that he was a
sophomore in high school uh when the
pandemic hit and so he spent basically
half a school year learning from home uh
and he said that he lost motivation
right it's really hard to go from like
being in a classroom with a teacher to
being at home learning on Zoom right uh
when you're laying in bed listening to
someone teach you algebra right this is
not the same thing uh and his braids
actually did slip uh through that
process but what he wrote in this essay
really motivated me because he said that
it was it was his family and his friends
that really helped him through that time
uh and his grades dipped right during
that time but he was able to bring them
back up he because he had people around
him who helped him do that and one
reason that I'm really passionate about
giving this talk is that like we're so
much better when we do it together we're
so much better when we're not burned out
and I think that we can help we can be
the generation that really tackles
burnout resistance and we let the
stresses that will inevitably happen in
life not get to us then we can do so
much more right we've we've been built
for this we've been through the fire
we've been tested if you're standing
here you made it congratulations let's
keep going let's build ourselves into
the better versions of who we are and I
really hope that this framework that I
shared with you is a part of that I hope
that I've shared tools that you can use
even today that you can have more
practices to help you take control over
your relationships that you can help get
rid of the things that are distracting
you that you can also so make sure that
you Revitalize your health invest in
your body right right you only get one
right there's no until we do cloning
technology you got one body so take care
of it
and I really hope that this framework is
a way that you all can build up the
reserves that you need to deal with
stress right the world is not going to
get less stressful
right there will be some other pandemic
level event that will hit the world
right maybe it's going to be economic
um hopefully won't be some viral thing
but it's going to happen but if there's
one thing that we learn from the
pandemic that we can make it
right we can go through life-changing
experiences and come out better for it
and so I really hope that you all can
invest in this framework and I really
believe that healthy teams build healthy
code
and this framework can be a powerful way
for you to invest in your own health but
also be a model for the people around
you that you work with with every day
right so many of the habits that I have
right now came from people I worked with
20 years ago who I don't even know where
they are right now but being around them
made an impact on me and I really hope
by sharing this framework that you begin
to model better behaviors so that the
people that you're working with now in
20 years even though they may not know
where you are they are all the better
for it because you help model burnout
resistance for them
so I really hope that as you go
throughout your careers that you keep
this framework in mind I use this it
works it's powerful I'm a better human
because of it and I think that it can
help you connect with your Humanity as
well so I will be cheering for you as
you do this please feel free to reach
out to me I'm very easy to find on the
internet I'm happy to talk to all of you
and I will be cheering for you right as
you help to build the best version of
who you can be all right thank you
welcome to NDC enjoy the conference
[Music]
foreign